[Música]
ahí estoy yo
nací en quito ecuador y crecí en la
ciudad era una niña citadina hasta que
tuve 7 años
fue entonces que mis papás se mudaron a
vivir en el campo en un valle que queda
como a 40 minutos de la ciudad
y es donde yo aprendí a sumergirme entre
los arbustos y en el monte para explorar
y observar insectos
pero sobre todo arañas
tanto me gustaban las arañas y a mis 10
años tenía una colección de 5000 arañas
vivas que coleccionaba en frasquito
vibrio
sin duda esta era mi favorita
en el mundo una de cada diez personas
tiene fobia a los insectos y tres de
cada diez tiene fobia a las arañas
ven esa carita de felicidad ya no era
una besos y entenderán que esquivar el
bullying como una ficción como esta en
la adolescencia no era tarea fácil así
que hice lo que la mayoría
dejé mi afición para tratar de encajar
así que me gradué del bachillerato
especializada en física y matemáticas y
luego entré a estudiar diseño gráfico
que era una carrera nueva en el ecuador
y creo que fue una buena decisión pero
como en la vida todo da vueltas una
madrugada muchos años más tarde
regresaba manejando desde la costa y a
la altura del bosque nublado como a una
hora y media antes de llegar a quito
parece en esta pequeña estación a cargar
gasolina y de pronto no podía creer lo
que estaba viendo
eran miles de polillas pegadas en la
pared y yo tres que revoloteaban en la
luz en seguida me bajé y me acerqué y
fue cuando todo conectó esa niña
entomóloga frustrada que había guardado
y escondido durante años salió a la luz
y revivió
y fue cuando todo tuvo sentido regresé a
casa y decidí volver y cogí una cámara
de fotos de un par de semanas más tarde
y regresé a la gasolinera pero que creen
que pasó no había una sola posición que
yo no me imaginé esto yo las vi aquí
resulta que las polillas cuando están
dentro del bosque
triangulan moviéndose alrededor de la
luz de la luna pero en ausencia de luna
o cuando es en su etapa temprana
menguante o creciente las polillas salen
en busca de salud y se van a las zonas
pobladas y es cuando se quedan tan
burlando alrededor del foco
como todo el mundo me dice polillas pero
si somos rivales lo que ustedes están
pensando ahora si los polillas tienen
fama de ser una plaga seas peludas
oscuras
pero la verdad es que como las vemos
detrás de la luz siempre los vemos así y
cuando nos acercamos a observarles
encontramos que esconden unos diseños
fantásticos
por ejemplo miren esto esto es una de
las primeras que vi le puse de apodo
carolina herrera
es muy de un modo sano
vaca
a esta le puse la cocinita porque es
como que tiene un pespunte alrededor me
encantaba
y así vive encontrando miles cada una
más hermosa que otra
desde los diseños más complejos
hasta unos inverosímiles
unos torna soles
unos geométricos
otros minimalistas
más exóticos
más caóticos a viejas miles y mientras
yo las seguía observando y admirando iba
aprendiendo sobre esto por ejemplo
sabían que en el mundo hay más de 150
mil especies de polillas
es muy loco pensar eso
ojo que estoy diciendo 150.000 de
polillas no de mariposas que a
diferencia de las polillas las mariposas
son diurnos
y tienen un apéndice al final de su
antena y cuando se posan llegan sus alas
hacia arriba las polillas que son en su
mayoría nocturnas en las antenas tienen
una forma de plumilla y cuando se posan
apoyen y abren sus alas hacia abajo y
así comencé a diferenciarlas y yo las
perseguía con mi cámara y no perdía la
oportunidad para salir del trabajo e ir
a observarlas y ellas me pasaban dejan
muy amigables a diferencia de las
mariposas no salían volando sino que
estaban ahí yo les hablaba le consentía
les abría las citas y cada vez se volvía
más divertido incluso mi familia y mis
amigos a veces llegaron a creer que
estaba un poquito forzado porque les
hablaba las bolitas y de creo que en la
realidad sí sí se volvió un poco una
obsesión una pasión que no podía dejar
de hacer
entonces dije tengo que hacer algo y
comencé a ilustrar digitalmente estos
bichitos porque quería de alguna forma
mostrar esto que yo veía en la luz del
foco este movimiento esta repetición
entonces comencé a hacer estos patrones
pero resulta que nadie me creía cuando
yo le mostraba esto a los colegas a los
amigos les decía miren qué hermosas
estas políticas no son polillas no es
real son feas los polillas ni siquiera
mis amigos biólogos me creían realmente
entonces decidí hacer el mismo ejercicio
pero incluir las fotos para que no quepa
la menor duda de que eran reales que
existían y que cada una era más linda
que otra
y así comencé a hacer este análisis de
la simetría de sus alas y de la
composición y observaba los detalles que
tenían cada una iba jugando con el
movimiento y con la cromática que era
fascinante me encantaba ver cómo hacían
este contraste con los lugares donde se
apoyaban por ejemplo la madera el
cemento el metal no era en esa
mariposita romántica que se va la flor
eran estos eres un poco underground o un
poco urbano y esto hacía que se vean más
lindos para mí cada vez más hermosos así
que pasé cuatro años haciendo esto en
mis tiempos libres
y cuando tuve reunidas muchas dije voy a
hacer un libro voy a mostrarles para la
gente
así que mi aventura busca la editorial
y dije el libro se va a llamar pachanga
pachanga porque sinónimo de fiesta de
rumba y yo si esta analogía con estas
damas de la noche que salían con sus
bellos trajes a bailar a la luz del foco
entonces fue que una editorial alemana
chiquita decidió tomar el vector
trabajamos un año más o menos en la
edición del libro y cuando yo estuve
listo hasta me sorprendieron diciendo lo
que lo iban a hacer en japonés cosa que
nunca me imaginé que iba a pasar
pero lo que tampoco imaginé es que mucha
gente después de esto me escribiría a
decirme que no volvería a matar a una
polilla
finalmente las bolillas mostrarían y
sorprenderían a muchos con su belleza
ese efecto de lo inesperado se volvió
una fuerza seductora que causaba mucha
curiosidad
y el libro pasa de ser de un libro de
diseño a un objeto que invitaba a
observar a observar cualquier forma de
vida no solo polillas
y la gente observaba y luego se quedaba
contemplando y luego acariciaban las
páginas libro generando esta experiencia
como de cercanía y de hasta afecto con
estos bichos verdes
son invisibles ahí es cuando comprobé
que las imágenes tienen el poder de
acariciar el espíritu y para mí esta fue
uno de los mejores recompensas
que viene luego
comencé a hacer experimentos para
aplicar los diseños a objetos a
productos y otras cosas
pero por otro lado llegaron propuestas
para participar en proyectos editoriales
en colaboración con amigos
biólogos fotógrafos naturalistas y
científicos para de alguna forma
rescatar otros bichos graves
por ejemplo sapos ballenas
o sos también me invitaron a hablar
sobre biodiversidad sobre cambio
climático sobre conservación y sobre
divulgación científica
y de alguna forma esto permitió que yo
siga con mi vuelo con este viaje
exploratorio
donde volví a hacer este ejercicio
maravilloso que es detenerme un rato y
acercarme a observar y luego interpretar
lo que veían mis ojos
tengo el privilegio de vivir en un país
megadiverso que es el ecuador que a
pesar de ser un país chiquito tiene
muchos ecosistemas y microclimas
y mostrar a través de mi gráfica esa
abundancia esa generosidad esa riqueza y
ese despliegue de formas y color
hace que mi profesión tenga sentido en
mi vida y es lo que me encanta
y en ese vuelo siempre se me vuelven a
aparecer estos seres invisibles estos
seres que nadie ve migrañas por ejemplo
o los insectos que en el bosque pasan
desapercibidos y es cuando me encanta
ver los detalles y volverlos a
representar para que la gente los vea en
grande
y de nuevo regreso volando hacia mis
políticas que están ahí que no se han
ido porque creo que hay pasando para
rato y en pachanga para todos y es
cuándo
reflexión sobre esa niña que un día dejó
su afición
solo para no sentirse rechazado y a la
que ahora yo le diría que abra sus alas
y salga a explorar sin miedo
porque después de todo
no es tan malo ser un raro
las cosas
a
[Música]